so you think you know something about
redheads huh how about you go yourself
you think all redheads are Irish I'm
from Russia but yeah Russia and Ireland
there's the same thing do you have the
rarest hair color in the world probably
not tricky
did you know that redheads need more
anesthesia during surgery it's true
it takes a big time to put us under what
can I say I guess we just don't go down
as easily as the rest of you losers do
you know that redheads are going extinct
we're basically like the unicorns of the
human world yeah it's cool if you call
me fire crotch so long as you don't mind
me setting your crotch on fire you heard
we're crazy in bed well that's
absolutely true
if by crazy you mean the best thing they
never have do you know who was a redhead
Mark Twain King father of American
literature you know who else was a
redhead everyone else who [ __ ]
matters Helen of Troy Vincent van Gogh
James Joyce Thomas Jefferson I don't
know the dude who invented America
Napoleon Malcolm X and Michael Caine
Fassbender if you want something to
bully wine upper nests they seem like
[ __ ]
you think all redheads are soulless
vampires that's actually true we're
gonna outlive all you old mother quads
and brains so next time kick of ginger
Day rolls around instead of being a dick
how about you don't instead because
we're actually pretty awesome
Wow does my carpet match the drapes how
about you go [ __ ] yourself